what's going on people we're gonna
watch ourselves some peacemaker one by
seven today be peaceful by hitting that
like button be vigilant by subscribing
and clicking that bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next peacemaker is up
full length watch along so you sync up
with the time code with us on peacemaker
over at our patreon page we come with superjet
to dab and check out everything over there
lastly nikki tim's boys at prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights where do you see my
backstory use rock and roll forever and tongue
case hot babes and smoke pot all day yeah yeah hey
me he had me to do that right
here let's go let your money
talk come on look at that mullis
no kicking no biting no grabbing
wow that is sick don't be a [
__ ] get in there and hate it
who needs [ __ ] fighting disturbing come on you
hit like a girl they had them bare knuckle box
oh that is
messed up keith it caused him some
brain trauma dumb [ __ ] you killed
your brother oh you [ __ ] you made the fight
and made money off of it that is so disturbing
what a transition i now understand this intro
the subtle tragedy of it yeah she probably planted
that diary in my trailer i know i couldn't trust
these people what the [ __ ] judo master judo
message oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it can't worry about
it now got all the peacemaker helmets programmed
in these ones at the police station they must have
been confiscated yesterday but these ones that's
got to be christmas god damn it harry is fake
of course it's a fake i was gonna write a
diary wouldn't get diary of your [ __ ] journal
vigilante and me might as well get
this done before they find us what done
kill this [ __ ] cow we are cool no a cow
maybe it's alien cow you did it didn't you
waller sent you here for this express purpose
did what planted a diary in peacemaker's trailer
yes wow i don't want to be here no more so i'm
leaving well then why the [ __ ] did you even come
because i lost my job and my mother offered
me this one mother yes oh it's all coming out
holy [ __ ] your mother is amanda waller hey you
need to get out of here she's waller's daughter
yeah i know oh no oh damn it how have you not seen
boondock scenes it's a classic visual acting jesus
you're always after me like guitars
i love it do your worst judo master
are you guys being a little nonchalant about
all this economos are you insinuating there is
a wrong time and a right time to rock
i feel like economos is going to die
yeah now that you've said that i can feel
it they're on 395 north about past the exit
i've got eyes
this nazi should not be so cool
why do i want an action figure
i'm not ready for it someone's
going to take the ball
no no no yeah oh [ __ ] will you do it what i
should have done long ago oh buddy oh my god
that's it man we gotta go come on get
up as long as eagley makes it out man
there's no wrong time
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh wow you left your
keys in the car what i was rushing
an [ __ ] man you're an [ __ ] so what do you
want to do tonight you want to go to the club
that's what's up
damn
oh damn open up
he's running like a spaz let's go
what animals it attached to
good call [ __ ] raccoons are hardcore man
no he's got a concussion
how do you know about the cow
nothing you can do will make me
you could have just joined us yeah
murm's officially gone you murdered him
the alternative was what without him his outfit
will have no chance of stopping us two clowns
and costumes and a couple of rejects two clowns at
costumes rejects sounds like the devil's re-checks
he did
oh
oh that's really sad
dang dog [ __ ] oh you gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me right now
wow
i love hotel fights
dumb [ __ ]
get them everywhere jeez that was a better fight
than when peacemaker fought judo mastermind
stop
how do it find you guys anyway he put a
gps tracking device in peacemaker's helmet
what oh no
i didn't know i thought they were expensive no
oh i got a piece of [ __ ] bat no eagley get back
in the car john can you get him in the car sure
no babysitting eagerly better not i swear to
god get in the car oh jesus he's not listening
get back in the car and crinkle a bag
or something i'll think you have chips
oh my gosh jeez yum yum
peacemaker running from nuts oh
my camerawork is so physical in
this episode what are you doing
there here why the [ __ ] are your pants all
the way down my clothes are touching my butt
live eagly please
ah
i'll kill you [ __ ] you think so
i knew you was unclean when you were
born when you killed your brother
i knew when you shaved your body
like a woman oh and now boys
i'm a piece of [ __ ] for listening
to you for all those years
i'm a piece of [ __ ] for not
killing you in your sleep like a girl
with a cougar no less i knew you couldn't
do it you [ __ ] cause i control you
whether or not i kill you you'll
never be able to get the [ __ ] away
oh that's what i'm talking about it's like
the more messed up version of civil war
oh wow i'm not supposed to be here that's why
i was packing up i just want to do whatever
job i need to retelling right from wrong ain't
advanced calculus because you're good at the job
and because we need every hand on
deck to try to go kill this cow
it's impossible we couldn't even get there in time
is this cow like a starrow level
kind of guy it's gotta be hey john
pause oh my god is there a
chance there's gotta be a chance
don't tease me i swear to god what's going
on dr hurwitz kindly stitched up eagerly
and vigilante's being a total freak dude
they saw us peacemaker and i were wanted
i never should have left him in my father's
garage for four years when i went to prison
i should have found somebody better to
take care of him like an ugly girl who
was desperate for love would have done
anything i wanted when i was locked up and
you know i could just broke up
with her the moment i got out
and i was a bad friend eagerly the only one
besides keith that never loved me for real
please god don't do anything you want
just keep
you know you're so happy to see me today wrap
his wings around me and hug me an eagle hugged
you oh yeah yeah i call him [ __ ] on that you
don't want to believe in miracles that's on you
take that selfie take it
miracles babe i just saw an eagle
hug a humor everything going on
how do we do this without mern we have someone
else that we can trust to lead us me now
oh you got this hard cord they'll do what they
can to move the cow out before we get there
according to what adds and
i overheard teleportation
go in there and we kick ass like butch cassidy
and the sundance kid they get slaughtered at
the end of that film freeze frame we hear a
bunch of bullets that doesn't mean they died
yes it does i don't think so i think they jumped
over those bullets right after that freeze frame
just like the devil's rejects i'm in
hell yeah hashtag me too yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's a big baby cow that's not like area
51 [ __ ] right there starship troopers yes
where's judo master i guess he's back at the hotel
just left him there let's suppose
credit's going to be more prayers
that's as good a guesses or something with
vigilante in the ribbon at the vet place
cleanliness is next to godliness and god knows i'm
close to him blood that's what you want to see if
you're not seeing any blood you're not scrubbing
hard enough start at the bottom slap your way up
keep going a little higher
swing the hips when you're drying especially
it's important to swing your hips and we're
finished now thank you very much thank you
for attending uh holy moses as well wild and
emotional show eagerly lives eagerly he glue
lives oh man made it no no previews oh the car
trailer reactors ain't watching trails
it's weird watching a show that you know is not
gonna get golden globe nominations but [ __ ]
yeah good call it's one of those shows right
yeah it's so good it's so good like it just
keeps getting better and maintains the humor like
it's sometimes i think like okay this is gonna be
the episode where we're like just serious this is
the serious intense one and while there there's
so much you know intensity in this one like this
one like brought me to tears i was on the edge of
my seat i was freaking laughing and i was like
man this is like the whole package right here
i'm really digging it so much and john cena's
performance is so strong i i just can't i
i don't know why i never suspected this level
of acting talent the guy has i guess it really
just depends on the right director or character
whatever or maybe he's always been this talented
and i just had no clue because he is phenomenal
here man um pushed to the lengths i think it's
interesting how they started off with the brother
death or you explain what happened with keith and
you know like the way they did those flashbacks
before those little glimpses of the traumatic
hauntings of that that like core memory for chris
it constantly seemed like okay maybe there's like
rough housing or messing around and then by an
accident he he killed him like something purely
unintentional where he he was where chris
was out of line as a kid and then you see
this flashback and you're like dude yeah this guy
freaking does auggie deserves to die this guy is
the worst he already was the worst and
then he just got worse than the worst in
this moment like you see him placing the bets
and he's exploiting his children's playtime
and put pitting them against each other and then
still walks out blaming chris for what happened
uh it is so absurd and like just
horrifying absolutely horrifying
and this whole time you've been seeing these
flashbacks you're like oh the weight of keith
that his death falls on chris's shoulders because
he feels personally responsible for it and the
way they've made this arc where after eagerly
his best friend it looks like he's been killed
by his own dad this comes out he starts unleashing
his rage everything underneath the surface and
he's you know just pouring it all on him like
it was your fault it's your response it was it's
his fault and it is like a it really did feel
like civil war you know he's got like an iron
man like red suit yeah helmet off he's beating
him he's on top of him the american symbol is
on top you know ready to kill him and said that
just follow through with someone actually dying
um it was really uh it was really fascinating
and then yeah of course when he kills him he's
going to be brought to tears because it's
still his father and he still loved him
in spite of all this meanwhile red dragon
be looking like the coolest mofo ever
wow you know he's pretty he's got like
this uh like 90s 2000s like cheese about
and it feels intentional because he's a
former he's the right words hero but the
former he's a former uh costumed super person yeah
yeah so it feels like appropriate to have it feel
like it's from an earlier era yes it is yeah
absolutely and i loved it i loved the way they
handled that that arc there is strong stuff yeah
and it was like the right size because you know
the white dragon suit has these like blasts and
this like rocket ability built in but it's not so
much that you can't believe that chris might have
a chance against him uh and yeah like this episode
like you said it was firing on all cylinders and
it did everything the show does across the board
really well all in one package which was the most
impressive to me like you said you laugh you cry
you know you're you're tense you're you're having
fun and sometimes all those things are having
are happening at the same time and uh yeah i think
it really is credit to the i wonder if maybe it's
just because dwayne johnson has such a sort of
mold in being the wrestler turned actor etc etc
that i almost sometimes wonder if that contributes
to the sort of everyone being surprised when john
cena has the chops because i feel like at this
point you could argue that john cena is maybe
a better emotional actor than dwayne johnson is
in certain cases in certain varieties of scenes
and i love like none of this would work if
that wasn't true or it wouldn't work as well
as it does if that wasn't true uh because yeah
this guy who is such a buffoon and such a joke
in certain ways is is also really really tortured
in a way that's very tangible and in a way that
i just loved what they were able to do with this
episode because so much plot happened but also i
feel like we got the most amount of emotional
resonance we've had so far it's probably my
favorite episode of the season up to this point uh
for for all those reasons and yeah even though you
know we've only spent one season with these
characters as of now and even though auggie
is you know a prominent character he's not like
the most prominent character and there are ways
in which i could imagine this feeling like oh damn
you know they already killed him off but this felt
very you know it felt like the story of how this
guy died not just a story about how he could have
died you know like the the showdown between them
felt so visceral and so personal and that you know
is most realized between auggie and chris but it's
throughout the episode with a lot of characters i
mean i feel like these intense sort of singular
interpersonal moments really pinned the episode
together and you see that with uh obviously chris
and auggie but also with adebayo and and harcourt
and even i mean even uh uh uh that moment shared
unknowingly between her and chris you know as
as chris is like crying over eagerly and praying
to god like yeah there's so many uh really great
character beats amid all the action and the chaos
well this was the revelatory episode where you see
arcs this is where the arcs come full circle
harcourt is you know the way she's spewing
her blurred lines of what lives matter and what
lives down when she's arguing without a bio
and you're starting to see that like you know she
really does care about chris she's spouting stuff
like he was your friend you know also her saying
he's my friend too and then at a bio uh getting
to see some of when she's getting defensive you're
like oh there's some of the wallers coming out of
her in this moment you know where she's trying
to justify her actions or like here's why you
shouldn't get on my ass about this like this this
choice made sense at the time clearly you know um
i know the actress's name but her um that her
performance was indicating that this is clearly
a defense mechanism and not today like this is
what she really thinks whereas like with waller
it really seems like waller thinks that
way yeah or her she doesn't agree with her
mom and she's just trying to please so you
know i think her performance is so strong so
you have this like exploration and and you know
even with it but by the end of that a bio would
realize where she belongs she like chooses to
stay on this one she has totally out where she
can just go home but she's choosing to stay on
this mission for something bigger than a job
and uh same thing with harcourt elevating to the
position of leader mirn you really see his true
intent here of like you already revealed it but
clearly willing to die and be like you guys carry
on the mission seemed like you communicated
something like kind of telepathically or some
[ __ ] to harcourt when uh when when harcourt was
slowing the butterfly in her hand yeah and um not
something vigilante's vigilante yeah he was proven
right for chris you know even very symbolically
with the peacemaker helmet like literally this
whole show has started off with peacemaker here's
who he is here's who you think he is now let's
strip away who's the man underneath the mask now
you get to this episode where literally the mask
is removed yeah this this this this physical thing
that is so connected so tethered to you know his
dad he literally gets the helmets from his father
and now that's removed that's gone now and
i think that's such an interesting choice
and that's such a key keystone part of the
peacemaker yeah it costs too many peacemaker
but it's a but it's a rich choice yeah yeah and
economos uh even he like he's just a guy behind
the computer now he just gets out in the field
and gets dirty gotta take out all the nazis you
know it was a really rewarding moment quite uh
yeah i like the relationship that's more with
hardcore how to buy and hardcore is becoming more
sensitive she even makes a choice with the that's
because normally you saw an episode where she did
just off an innocent person because our identities
were compromised and now here she decides not
to and so as you're seeing all these like great
arcs in here and then setting up for like the
big mission now just about with episode 8 stick
this episode's happening yeah well episode
8 is stick the landing ultimately and
i i feel like it will it you see with the
with the big creature at the end you're like
okay this is feeling more like the suicide
squad spin-off now yeah yeah yeah before
you're like okay you got a team of misfits here
who don't really know how to work together the
best and now they they're they're choosing to stay
together in spite of all the odds being stacked
against them against an alien threat and this
alien that they gotta kill is massive yeah and
they got very well protected and they got a horde
of these beings so they gotta take care of two
and yeah you're like okay i see some of the
more there's the similarities now more like
this now now this has been like the suicide squad
spin-off yeah which is good it was fine you know
i never i never really thought about it uh in
that regard and i i don't mind it at all and
[ __ ] judo master john talk about judo master
was badass and i mean i love the almost comic
strip quality judo master has had throughout this
series minus the introduction you know we meet
him with goth so he's a henchman and that makes
sense but from here it's like they just kind of
have to keep him contained and i agree that that
fight scene in the hotel room was i think one of
the standouts for the season and i think it did
actually outstrip the one between him and chris
because in the 2000s we were getting like a lot of
like those hotel fight scenes well yeah especially
like jason bourne movies and stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah well since we got a fight scene like
that we're just like oh it's brutal they're using
the items around them they're thrashing into stuff
anytime someone like breaks a sink or a
toilet yeah like oh yeah this is a nasty
like rough and tumble fight scene and and you
know throughout it's especially apparent in the
judo master scenes even outside the convenience
store where he whips those two guys ass is like
the camera work in this episode was so visceral
and you'd have things it's like shots where it
feels like the camera is right in the action
or or gets you know hit with you know debris
and stuff like that and yeah it's like it's so so
physical and so pulpy and so violent but in a very
in a way that doesn't break the fun like again
that's one of the charms of james gunn is like it
is bone crunching and gross in certain respects or
or just cringe-worthy in certain respects but also
uh is just so cool and i love how like out of all
these characters that have been so fleshed out
judo master has remained a complete constant every
time we have seen he's got his snacks he doesn't
say much he's got an attitude and he'll kick your
ass and that's that's it that's that character
and i wouldn't be surprised if he shows up one
more time before the season's over or or maybe in
like the the maybe like some kind of weasel style
stinger you know at the end of the finale episode
now saving the best part for last equally eagley
holy balls man since the first episode i've been
like that eagle's gonna die isn't it i'm holding
on so worried and then this episode made me go shh
like i when i was first thinking i feel like
economos was gonna die my real thought was
i'm feeling eagle's gonna die but i don't to
put it out there so you sacrificed economists
he'll take anyone before he could and then it
just started seeming like they were really hinting
towards it you know clearly they're not afraid
to kill off animals uh and [ __ ] like this and
james gunn's not afraid to kill off animals
in his projects so and in his private life
yeah i was surprised they didn't do anything to
the raccoons when they found the helmet dude i
thought they were gonna shoot the racket yeah i
thought they were gonna make it i i i appreciate
the restraint on those things but yeah it's clever
how they how it's all tied in it's neat because
even though they swap out directors like brad
anderson mr andrew brad anderson directed this
episode but james gunn wrote every one of them
so it's cool when you could see how connected
all these things are like establishing in the
last episode when equally in the field and like
taking out some some of them cops so it's like
okay yeah this isn't some random thing like if
there was just introducing this episode it'd be
like what the [ __ ] yeah like we were doing this
before you know and so like you're just putting
an excuse here to get him in this this perilous
situation so yeah you have that where he's
like taking out some of the kkk kind of guys
i think they're gonna have like a truck hit him
or something like that when he's just out on the
road yeah yeah he's like trying to work you're
just gonna shoot him yeah just they they really
the way they played with the audience they they
played it like a horror game we have sharing him
in this guy like they're following him and hold
on we're uploading something simultaneously can
you just tap that john yeah thanks um yeah so
i thought that they were uh they're gonna kill
him off but then that scene when he is in the
vet is like that's that's so encompassing of
everything of what makes this show
so good you have the chris character
he's saying [ __ ] sincerely and it's funny but
then you're also crying uh at least i was i was
really yeah i was [ __ ] it was get into me and
then and then to have that full circle moment
where she sees it like i like the use of the
flashback that was really good yes sometimes
i was in movies like we don't need the flashback
but the use of the flashback helped enhance the
humor it was moving in this like angelic way
yeah well yeah cause it's not for exposition
no no yeah yeah it's almost an exposition
free flashback in a sense i mean it does
function to remind you but yeah no it felt like a
cinematic choice of a flashback um eagley man he's
my man hugging an eagle i hope this isn't some
misleading words first episode first moment yeah
as it stands man this is uh this is truly awesome
what a way to kick off 2022 with that show
yeah that's enough and um i feel like it's a
pretty appreciated gem it's just not available
in some countries right now so that's why yeah
yeah but they say it's uh it's hbo's number one
show right now so you know what else they got
euphoria i'm sorry z4 he's the number one oh
yeah like foreign number one maybe it'll take the
crown back once peacemaker finishes up next week
i was surprised to hear that too because how
did you hear that i like it like this past week
people were talking about it because at first it
was creating out euphoria a couple of weeks ago
i was seeing not from like the reputable sources
but i was seeing like youtube videos about like ah
man peacemakers failing because of wokeness
and then like like a week later then i started
seeing like other places like variety being
like peacemakers like the hot top rated show
maybe maybe it's that i don't know if it's
like a difference in like how people rated
it versus viewership but it was pitched as being
their top show right now it was pitched as being
more views than boba fett yeah i think that
changed when a certain character appeared poof
but it's been doing really really well from what
i understand i mean euphoria is a juggernaut
yeah but this maybe has the edge because
it's the first season i don't know
all right guys well thank you so much for being
here what did you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below you can subscribe leave
a like and uh last but not least do a patreon
anissa oliva anisa you know what
screw jokes you've been amazing you're
you're just like a total gem you ask for
nothing from us you've been so loyal to
us for so long so supportive and you've
also gone way above and beyond for us and
more ways i've lost sincerely i've lost so
much track of just how far you've gone above
and beyond for us so just know you're always in
my mind and heart you matter so much to me and
you're just one of the coolest [ __ ] i've
ever met it's a good way to put that you are
super cool and we do not deserve your love yeah
you're you're you're thebomb.com and uh i love
you and it is one of my life's goals to meet you
one day in person talking on the phone talking
various video chat yeah yeah
one day in person it'll happen
thank you so much for remaining
loyal to us this entire time you rock
you